yo it's it ever crops being season 2 the
first shot take away the second season
of a show like anime crimes of vision is
both easier and some eventually more
difficult so on one hand you've already
kind of established what the world is
you can stop some of the rules of the
world yeah so you have that side of it
to build off of but on the other hand
you have to figure out a reason to come
back and revisit this world so for the
second season one of the things we want
to do is expand the scope of the anime
crimes that you were going to be seeing
hardest thing that happens in the first
season is a Gundam gets broken waffle so
for season 2 let's have this be like an
actual serial killer like people die but
season 1 sort of like every week there's
a different crime it's like a cop show
season 2 is a little bit more like a
drawn-out movie because we're following
this sort of one storm course storyline
that characters doesn't arrest through
it season two is going to be bigger more
intense emotionally visually
dramatically I'm really excited to see
how people respond to it once it comes
out
[Music]